do you remember your childhood
not really i got a boil on my
on my nut sack before getting on a toy
antique toy tractor
i'm sorry sit there again
you know what a boil is
[Music]
tractor with things that just lift up
with the two wheels in the front
and had the pedals that go this was an
old one
right and
something about that one there i
remember
us sitting on that seat
jesus has made it clear throughout my
life in different times that
he doesn't want me for him in the ground
so steve tell me where you're from i'm
from um
i spent the last like 14 years in maine
in birchton maine that's where i was
born at the age of two we moved to
southern illinois
which is where i call home but i haven't
been actually home for 20 years
you got here
i spent the last 14
14 years in maine in graceland maine
my family divorced it was very big
it sucked um
and i have gone through the divorce and
then after that
it was you know i go stay with my father
and find out he's
gonna beat me with a belt all the time
so then i go back to my mother
and i'm like take to the lesson the two
evil i guess
so there's lots of drugs and alcohol
here in skid row are you involved in any
of that
yeah i mean since i got here i mean it's
like things i need
the drugs the ones you go to
[Applause]
when i first got here i was a social
drinker
and uh
that that's interesting there's
interesting stories
um
what are you using now
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just on some
prescription meds from uh no phil
pharmacy
uh prescription dates for what
i'm trying to get ssi and
it's not trying i i actually you know
they they do think i have a problem but
they just don't know
they don't know exactly um
whether or not i'll be able to work
full-time or part-time these things
but i i mean will i be able to handle
full-time work schedule
that's a lot for somebody who has a
mental disability
it's going through periods of
uncertainty what is your disability
i've been diagnosed before schizophrenic
chemical imbalance
what did you say at what age did were
you diagnosed with
[Music]
12.
uh after i've been able to pick your
family
and yeah
i would have never went to the mental
health
clinic period i would have roughed
through it if it wasn't for my dear
mother
steve holden i'm 40
40. have you worked
throughout your life have you had jobs
yes what jobs have you had um
i started out i had 19 different jobs in
in illinois and i worked in
from there on i wore i've done oil field
i've done factory um
factory factory i've washed dishes
it's a dishwasher a couple times i had a
paper route
[Music]
i worked at mcdonald's
which was your favorite job
i think cows prepare this summer
uh that was what she needed she needed
she said see that boy there she said he
doesn't look very smart
she said do you want to work for me this
summer
for minimum wage feeding the cows i'm
rolling the grass
i don't know how she knew that i would
be able to do the stuff that needed to
be done but without asking i just
started fixing the stuff steve
um is there schizophrenia in your family
so everybody in my opinion is dealing
with the same issues that i
am in my uncle john yes talks to himself
and your family is where
[Music]
in ohio do you speak to them
near cincinnati yes
i'll facebook more
than often or not
and that's been just me uh them and i
for
20 years i've had no friends
you have no friends i haven't had it
for the past 20 years it's been just
family and i i have let my friends go
for bigger things
more important things
i went for three months this year
without even having
an ejaculation and it was good
it was good to not have to be bothered
by the ejaculation
it was a good time
[Music]
it was bad to be better
it was good to have no ejaculation
that disproves that god was involved
somehow or
it had something to do with my health
and for three months i didn't
he let me be in peace
does sexual frustration irritate you
is it a problem
do i struggle
will somebody else answer the question
for me